Awesome thank you, Sam,
and welcome, everyone.
We're really excited to have
this kind of pre RStudio
global session.
So as another person in
RStudio, just really
glad to have you all here.
Thanks for taking part of your
week to spend time with us.
So I'm going to jump right in.
We only got a couple of
minutes here through kind
of first thing I
want to do is talk
a little bit about conceptually
how we think about data science
here at RStudio, how
that applies to pharma.
And then we'll look at some
of the exciting updates
that we're making to support
that conceptual framework.
So data science, we like to talk
about it as kind of a journey.
You start out with this
timeline.
Do you mind presenting your screen
so it's full screen?
Yes.
Thank you.
Sorry about that.
Yeah, I know.
No worries.
So how we think about
data science as a journey.
It's a very iterative process,
as I'm sure you're all aware.
It starts with a hypothesis.
There's development and data
involved in that development.
There is collaboration
with others,
with other teams,
other stakeholders.
And then at the end is
some type of deliverable,
whether that's automation,
or handoff to the FDA.
And so in pharma,
oftentimes what
this looks like is something
like early stage research where
you're developing that
hypothesis that might evolve
into a full blown
experimental design and trial
and then into something
like a report or submission.
It might look more like
manufacturing or marketing.
And those are also key
parts of the pharma journey,
just determining some
type of objective.
And then iterating to decide if that
was the right objective, maybe
coming up with models and
doing production scoring.
And so there's a lot
of different ways
this kind of journey
can be realized
in the pharmaceutical space.
But what I want
to show you today
is how we're building
tools to help
and where those tools fit
into the different parts
of this journey.
So on the top, you
have some major updates
we've released in the
last year to RStudios,
professional products.
So on the development side,
we've done a lot of work
to ensure that RStudio scales
as your data in the richness
of that data grows by allowing
you to tap into things
like the Cloud in
the middle part
there. Where you're thinking
about collaboration
and iteration,
we've done a lot of work on a
tool called Rstudio Connect
to help you dynamically
share content.
And then when it comes to
hardening in automation,
we've done a lot of work on a
project called package manager
to ensure that whether
you're doing the analysis
in R or Python, whether it's
using CRAN or Bioconductor,
you have the correct packages
and dependencies that you need
to be really certain
that your work's
reproducible and reliable.
So those are things in blue.
Those are kind of all available
today as part of RStudio
Team, which is that
professional platform for doing
data science that you'll hear
a little bit about this week.
But on the bottom
may be more exciting.
Are some of the developments,
specifically in the open source
community that we've partnered
with pharmaceuticals,
the companies to bring to
really support the workflows
that you're doing day to day.
So the big one that we're
going to look at today
is this new kind of reimagined
R Markdown that's actually
helpful throughout the journey
of creating hypotheses,
collaborating and sharing.
So we're going to spend
some time looking at that.
There's new packages for
the middle layer of work
where you're building models,
specifically tidy models,
is going to be a major
part of the conference.
There's some work on Shiny and
R Markdown that's being done.
One example of that work
is the thematic package.
And then on the far
end, here's something
that's really kind of specific
to the pharmaceutical space,
is the work that we're doing
around validated submissions.
And so one key
element of that work
is a tool called gt,
which is in R package
for creating tables and then
some work around validation
and how different
platforms and tools that
are supportive of
submissions can be validated.
So let's drill into a few
of those specifically.
And then actually kind
of look at what's new.
And so kind of going
actually backwards.
We'll start with those
validation documents
I mentioned.
These are documents that
outline for packages that
are affiliated with RStudio.
So things like Shiny and R
Markdown, tidyverse, tidy models,
as well as RStudio Team,
those professional products.
These documents outline how
to think about their software
development lifecycle
for compliance.
So if your QA team
has ever asked you,
how can we be sure
that R is producing
kind of valid and correct
results, that's a big question.
R is a huge ecosystem that
some of the later presentations
today are going to talk
through how to think
about answering that question.
But we're excited to announce
some documents that hopefully
will just answer that
question for you, for these
RStudio affiliated packages.
So be sure to check
those documents out.
And we won't read
through them today,
that would take a lot more than the
couple of minutes we have left.
The second thing that
I wanted to mention we
talked about in the
submission space,
it's really critical that
you have a package management
solution.
And so RStudio offers RStudio
package manager as one option
there.
And we're excited to announce
Bioconductor as a new addition
to that offering.
And so just kind of quickly
show you what that looks like.
If you're using packages
from Bioconductor,
you might be familiar
with this notion
that Bioconductor does its
releases about twice a year.
And so package manager
makes those same releases
available to you.
There's instructions for
inside of package manager
for how to set up.
One of the things we're
really excited about
is that previously,
there is kind
of no way to keep CRAN
and Bioconductor in sync.
And so if you're using
RStudio package manager,
you can actually go ahead and
keep those two things in sync.
So that as your
working with packages,
and small packages
from CRAN, you'll
be guaranteed to get
the right results.
I'm showing you today kind of
an internal version of this,
but you can actually
go to package manager
dot RStudio,
dot com, which is
a free version of the package
manager service and the Bioconductor
offering is available
there as well.
So if you want to source
Bioconductor packages, as well as
kind of a frozen
version of CRAN that
will match the
Bioconnector release.
And that's available
to you today.
So I know we're going to have
in rapid fire succession,
but the last thing I
wanted to talk a little bit
about with some of those
changes in the open source
ecosystem around R Markdown
and some of the packages
that work with R
Markdown to create
these beautiful documents that
you might be using internally
or for things like submissions.
And so I'm going to talk about
two things, an update with
R Markdown.
And this package called GT.
And so we'll kind of
combine both of those
into a single demo.
But before we hop
to the IDE, just
to give you a
understanding of gt it's
a package short for
grammar of tables.
So it's very
similar to ggplt2,
which is the grammar of plots.
And so what GT is
all about is allowing
you to write really expressive
and flexible code for creating
tables, and then take
that code and use
it to render those tables
wherever you need them.
So the same code can be
used to create tables
that render to RTF things
like Word documents
or to render HTML.
And so that's kind
of the concept.
And I'll show you what
that package looks like
and how you use it
inside of RMarkdown.
So let me switch
over to RStudio IDE.
This is all open source.
So you can use the
latest version of RStudio
on your desktop or on a
server with these packages.
And basically the
workflow that you'll see
is similar to what
we're looking at here.
So I have some data.
This is just kind of raw
data inside of a data frame.
And to turn that data
into a table with gt,
it's very similar to how you
might create a plot with
ggplot2.
So you start with this gt function.
And then you add pieces to
get to the final end result.
So in this case, we're
adding some summary rows.
We're add a grand
summary of summaries
and then we're telling GT how
to format the different text
cells.
So I'll actually, go ahead and
run this code for you.
And we can take a
look at the output.
So this is going to
create for us a gt table.
And by default, that gt table
is going to be in HTML.
So it's right here inside
of our R Markdown document.
And you can see kind of
what I had described.
We start out with this
data that's in a table.
And then we're
adding summary rows.
We're adding a grand summary,
which is this top row here.
And then we're doing
some formatting.
You can see things like
footnotes are fully supported,
different sections of
tables are supported.
You can have custom
formatting, column headers.
So a lot of flexibility in
creating the table just the way
you want.
And that's already
pretty exciting.
But it gets even better because
with a single line of code,
you can take the same
table that we've created
and save it to a
different output format.
So if you need this
table to exist inside
of a Word document, you can
create that RTF version
of the table that will
then render inside of Word
or inside of whatever
other formatting
tool you want to use.
So that's the really kind
of exciting update to gt.
I mentioned, there
is something else.
So kind of the last
thing I want to show you
is this update to R Markdown.
And the way it works is
inside of the latest version
of the IDE.
There's this new option to
essentially render the document
as you go.
And so by clicking this kind of
magic button here, what I get
is an interactive editor
for the R Markdown document.
So our code is still here.
You can see our
table is still here.
But but I actually
have the rendering
of R Markdown in real time.
And so why would you do this?
Because it turns out.
It makes it really
easy to create
rich and powerful documents.
And so as an example, I'll go
ahead and insert another table.
And this table will take a look
at some of the features that
are available here.
So as I type markdown,
that markdown is going
to be rendered in real time.
I can even put in
things like emojis.
So there's full support
for interactive editing,
and you can even do things
like render Latex in line.
You can see the
preview shows up.
And then the output shows up.
So as you're writing, it
becomes a really powerful way
to create and see exactly
what you're doing.
But under the hood, it's
all still R Markdown down.
So I can always
go back and forth.
If I wanted to, to
the original document.
That's just a plain text file.
So we're excited about how
all these things together
can hopefully help you
in your day to day work,
achieve that in the
science journey.
And so I'll end things there.
This is just a little
bit of a preview, a taste,
a sampling, if you
will, of what's
to come both today at
RStudio conference.
So I hand things back
over to you, Sam.
Thanks for having me.